also the size of my head sunglasses are
very versatile see that guy that you
match with on tinder anything happens
but bad he was like hi I'm Liz hi I'm
Julia
we're both college students we just met
today and we're here to swap college
survival kits I love college it's a lot
of work but it's fun my school is great
food it's available until like two I am
yeah I hate cooking so just that
availability for me is yeah that's
wonderful this is only my second
semester but it's a ton of fun I'm
learning a lot I've met so many awesome
and like fun and friendly people
the worst thing is the cost tuition is
expensive books are expensive also the
bathrooms I don't know if this is true
but the whole communal bathroom thing
hairs everywhere the hair bows are
disgusting I haven't gotten a care
package before my friend came home with
some socks for me with [ __ ] seized on
them and they were just like yeah I
could just kind of feel you're gonna
have a bad day and I did so that was
really nice when my brother went to
college me and my mom sent to a bunch of
stuff I feel like I haven't actually my
parents every cookies once and they kind
of really crushed when something asked
me but the thought was there they're fun
today I've got my box I need to fill it
up one thing I got was a fanny pack that
you're going to a party you're like I
can't really bring like a backpack or a
purse because that's just like a lot to
carry a fanny pack
he and sanitizer is such a necessity
because they're just germs everywhere
else got advil liqui-gels very important
for day after that party since we're
like the health grind right now I also
got essential oil sometimes I'm anxious
I was like
it is actually really tempted to just
pop ones Nutella this is why I called my
depression food you know class goes bad
fail something boy
I just sit down my spoon and Tom
McCullar I sit straight and come to me
like a late-night snack I'm vegetarian
so I get this friend once a guy feel
like sad because of like a bunch of
reasons fuzzy socks hydration but yellow
is a fun color there's a regular old
planner there's a super important way
these LED strip lights they just help
make your dorm feel more like home yeah
it's like old philosophy that's
applicable nowadays and it's my favorite
my friends at school we always like
maybe Joey no time doing time to like
encourage me in the box
cool yeah let's wrap it now
here's your box I just tried to get
things that I found that I use like
everyday in my dorm like a big fan of
you every Watson just tea in general
yeah yeah I feel like it's a very frat
boy like it's good to like print out
photos that's if they don't do that this
is finals week
yes exactly Neil correctly I don't own
that that's perfect and I need a chance
like the color yellow yes I do
it's one of my like sorority colors so
mm-hmm
we got a little essential oil I'm a big
league lavender girl
sighs are cute I don't know you put your
strong beautiful and powerful you got
this
Julia Wow this is true I'll really not
it's like mental health it's greater
than gpio just greater than men or
whoever whatever gender you're attracted
to love that don't forget that you need
water
well obviously oh this is amazing also
the size of my head I'm a huge Nutella
fan I literally just eat it by the
spoonful yeah that's why I just sit down
my spoon and some Nutella I see it
straight let's see this is fun fanny
pack I just have one for like parties
yes awesome thank you you have no idea I
literally was just timing roommate that
I need another hook yes amazing okay
look yeah letters from a stoic so this I
think is like the best philosophy okay
very like you can live your life by it
this is awesome
thank you that's pretty cool sir these
are great it gets cold here at night I'm
such a weather with planner I'm a huge
planner girl and sounds very cute yeah
well maybe go at the fanny pack you guys
oh my gosh yeah I live by this this is
advil gotta have it the liquid gels next
level I think you know that these are
good I'm Lee excite about the book cuz
I'm a tone there it's all definitely be
reading this these aren't even things I
want these are things I need it's really
good like small acts of kindness even if
it's not like buying someone something
but if it's like maybe a note or like
this small things are are really
important